[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is a good decision?
I recommend placing a scheduled
cesarean section patient
in room five.
Nurse Merideth can
take care of her.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is a good decision?
I recommend placing a new
patient in triage bed T5.
What is a bad decision?
A bad decision would be to place
a scheduled cesarean section
patient in room 14 and have
nurse Kristen take care of her.
Ginger, what's a good decision?
I recommend placing a scheduled
induction patient in room 10.
Nurse Merideth can
take care of her.
Ginger, what's a bad decision?
A bad decision would be to place
a scheduled cesarean section
patient in room 14 and have
nurse Amy take care of her.
I agree.
[MUSIC PLAYING]